finance for dummies specifically
index funds
for dummies i'm glad we're doing this
i've had questions
you've had questions about index funds
yeah index funds are a thing
you know how fired up i am about t-pain
spending all his money on a negative
side i'm that fired up about index funds
nobody
nobody is this fired up about index
funds
usually index funds are freaking nerds
all right i've got the index fund and i
have some people shut the
i like index funds index funds has made
me a millionaire
so listen up dude i'm listening okay so
listen up what are a low cost end
there's a beginner's guide apparently if
you want to pull this thing off it's up
okay so let me wait maybe before we get
into what an index fund is why you
should invest in index fund here i'm
going to give an analogy hey david
you're a sports fan yeah i am okay who
you liking the super bowl this year i
don't know i don't watch football okay
anyway
who do you think's gonna win
um i don't know the team that's doing
the best right now that's awesome great
advice there right there thank you
patreons patriots ravens patriots
patriots are one and two ravens i think
are two in one anyway
the analogy here is this here's a little
metaphor for you nobody knows nobody
knows who's going to win the super bowl
so rather than trying to bet or pick the
winners and losers to pick the team that
you think is going to win
why not bet on the entire nfl
uh-huh
nfl
you think you think i don't think i've
learned something from being a [ __ ]
dolphins fan
losers
losers went to the game against the
bills the other day they lost like 35
zip loser bill
35's i'm just betting on the entire nfl
and if you understand that rather than
picking one team that you think is going
to win oh
my green bay packers are going to do it
this year nope
the cowboys here nat
huh go niners where
she bet on all of them bet on all of
them
put a buck on each that's index
investing let's break this down so
rather than picking a certain team pick
the entire league okay okay
all right all right here we go let's
let's let's let's cause right off the
bat it feels like you're going to lose
more than you're going to win
like there's only one winner yeah people
who gamble lose no all i'm saying about
okay with this analogy all right but go
on so anyway let's what's an index fund
let's talk about that so that's an
analogy right there okay with that in
mind you're going gonna pick the entire
nfl league 32 teams i don't know who's
going to win i'm buying all 32. yeah
what does that mean all right so an
index fund is basically a portfolio
stocks saying i don't know what stock is
going to go up but what is going down
just buy them all
okay so basically it can be stocks or
bonds all good what have you and it's
designed to mimic the performance of a
financial market index you always hear
the s p 500 well there's the dow 500 or
there's the nasdaq or the russell 2000
these are known as
indexes aka
indices
indices yeah yeah not under the sea
in indices exactly so the reason that
you invest in an index fund is because
it makes it easy
it's like a mutual fund
right
but very
much lower cost what's a mutual fund
okay it's a basket a pool of funds so
rather than picking out stock i like
this stock i like this stock this stock
went up the stock went down how about
this stock i don't know about this i
don't know i i got no time to pick it up
yeah yeah they're all moving buy them
all just buy them all one let's get them
all we're gonna do a fun we're gonna put
a pool of stocks together uh 50 no
100 nah 500 now you're talking my
language that's the s p 500. so
basically they got lower expenses and
lower fees and actively managed funds
will talk about actively managed and
they follow what is known as a passive
investment strategy that's the basically
the premise of index so
we talked about this there's a couple of
well-known indexes out there s p 500
standard poor's 500 that's the most
common index those are the 500 largest
companies in america i think there's
actually 505 currently in the s p 500
but anyway who's counting so those are
the larger largest publicly traded
american companies name a company
they're probably on the s p 500
companies you know tesla they're on
there microsoft they're on there right
so
you see where i'm going here i see what
you do starbucks there they are
s p 500.
you want to pull that up
pull up the s p 500 pull this mp5 s and
p standard and pours there we go you
also got the dow jones the 30 largest
companies in america 30 only 30. nasdaq
those are the tech stocks right tech
stocks
and then you get the russell 2000 those
are like small cap companies anyway
active versus index what the hell does
that even mean so typically
before index indexing came around
passive investing came around which is
basically it's down
what is
yeah that's fine pull up pull up images
of s p 500 s p 500 images and i'll tell
you where to go
you don't have to put today just put s p
500 images all right anyway before um
index you had to do active investor
right so the index i think one i started
in the 70s but then it really became a
thing in the 90s etfs exchange traded
funds um there's a guy called jack bogle
we'll pull up his link he started a
company called vanguard and vanguard is
the company that was like why
why are we always trying to beat the
market you get all these stock pickers
and basically the the what they the
analogy is this let me try to use this
analogy
um
there was a book
and they called it a long
a walk down wall street
and they basically said this analogy
to pick a stock
that you think is gonna
be a winner yeah is like picking
a drunk person's
movements walking home like a drunk
person like yeah you know he's doing
this whole thing oh he's gonna oh no
that's like picking a stock
what and that's active investing is it
going this way is it going this way i
don't know should we go this can we go
that we got this i don't know
80 percent of stock pickers don't win
yeah 80
what index investing does it or or
passive investing and says look i don't
know who's going to freaking win bro i'm
just buying all the stocks yeah and over
time did you find the pi i mean i went
on here i'll get i'll show you what to
do i'll show you what to do all right
they're there basically
um smp5 yeah instead of and put the put
the and symbol
and put it all together there you go
pull that up
keep scrolling down
keep scrolling down scrolling boom this
one right here
make that one large here's the companies
in the s p 500 you get the big dogs
amazon apple right microsoft do you see
how much bigger those are yeah let me
get it okay that where'd that thing go
let me get into okay
but basically saying rather than trying
to pick
you do you know what um spg stands for
spg yeah it's right here no i don't know
either okay i couldn't tell you do you
know what uh gis stands for no clue
couldn't tell you either but do you know
what all these things added up are
that's the s p 500. so rather than
saying i don't know is this one going to
be red today or green today i don't know
who knows how the [ __ ] do you know buy
the whole thing
and then over time it goes up you know
over time historically s p has returned
10 annually over the last
10 years from 2011 to
uh 2020
it was about a 11.5 percent uh to keep
things in perspective people talk about
the uh nasdaq tech stocks
right
nasdaq um
separate from the s p it's specifically
you know to get the new york stock
exchange you get the nasdaq these are
exchanges
nasdaq's gone up about 17
um
but here's the deal get getting back to
index funds um
you don't actively invest in index [ __ ]
the whole point is just like dude put
the money in chill out let let the
market do what it do
don't worry about it your costs are low
you're not getting in you're not getting
out you're not trying to time the market
you have time in the market not trying
to you know time the market and then
over time you build wealth that's the
key to that's the key to building wealth
that's how jack
jack bogle founder of vanguard was like
this is how it's done bro
this is how it's done so what's what's
the ticket to
into a low cost oh okay so here we go
low-cost index fund yeah there you go so
um
so basically again it just matches the
index you say if people say the whole
point of active investing here let me
just let me just break this down let me
break this down the whole point of
active investing is to beat
the market
i beat the market right the market did
10 i did 15. for sure the market did uh
11 i did 13. the market did 10 i did 20.
80 of the time you're not beating the 10
right that's the bottom line eight out
of ten people closer to nine out of 10
people cannot beat just the market
meaning they can't get 10 returns on
their investment
so you're paying all this money for
active investors to not beat the market
so what jack bogle vanguard said was
like look
just pay a very little bit of money keep
your fees low keep it simple bro like if
he was a bro he would have been like
look
just keep it simple bro just keep it
simple yeah keep your costs low stop
trying to time the market and actively
invest and just invest in the index and
over time you're going to win and you're
going to use your friend compound
interest to help you win so basically
within within the s p 500 to use the nfl
analogy every quarter they basically
what is called rebalance
it's like kind of like every every year
you got to make the team every quarter
you got to make the team yeah if you're
not doing good you get cut from the s p
500 right it's like teams are always
improving so it's not the same 500 that
are here today won't be here january 1st
next year look at that you ain't doing
good you're not in the 500 because the
whole point
of the 500 the whole point
is for you to say how's the american
economy doing take a look at these 500
companies look at them
some are doing well some are not doing
well some are doing okay some are up
some are down but overall this is how
the american stock market is doing so
it's an indicator an index is an
indicator s p 500 is an indicator of how
the overall markets are doing gotcha so
rather than being like like if i ask you
what stocks do you like you'll be like i
don't know yeah just like yeah i invest
in the s p 500 i do index investing and
things are going very well look at that
dude i i i say that
anywhere yeah i'm a genius genius let's
take a look at this anyway this guy's
got his [ __ ] together so index funds are
a hot thing right now so to give you an
example between 2010 and 2020 the last
10 years
index funds have grown from 19 of the
total fund market to 40
so they've doubled basically people used
to do active investing let me give you a
little perspective here i don't know if
we have any wolf of wall street jordan
belfort fans i'm sure we do but back in
the day
if you needed to make a stock trade in
the 80s
call up a dude yeah he'd give you his
little spiel
he'd sell you on some [ __ ] that maybe
you didn't even want
he would take a commission
and whether you won or lost money or
gained or lost money he would make some
money so you got a guy that you barely
trust cold calling you and you've got
this active investor thing going on
active investor means he's active he's
trading he's making moves he's doing all
that yeah passive he's like
the market did okay today
versus passive yeah so you'd have to
call the jordan belford of the world
whether you trust this guy or not he's a
guy in charge of your money now today
i'm not giving uh there are financial
advisors there are fire natural planners
that are very credible that still do
this but again 8 out of 10 of them don't
beat the market right so a lot of them
will just say look maybe you're better
served doing passive index investing
active
active trading
index passive chill out bro chill out
chill out bro
investing shouldn't be fun
until when just until so you need it
maybe maybe it's a maybe it's for
retirement yeah maybe it's ten years
maybe you gotta you got a game plan put
the money whatever it is forget about it
forget about it
let the pasta sauce marinate there we go
that's what it comes down to anyway
index funds grew from 19 to 40 of the
market share meaning people are hip to
the scene now who what are some index
funds that you guys should look into
here's a little there's a little hot tip
for you a little sauce tip here's three
low-cost s p index funds that i
basically checked out and said yeah
these guys are good fidelity fidelity
500 index fund the fx aix expense ratio
0.015 percent okay you got the schwab s
p 500 index s w p p x expense ratio 0.02
percent and then our friends at vanguard
the s p 500 etf v o o expense ratio 0.03
now you're saying
0.15 0.015 0.02 expense ratio 0.03
you're like what the [ __ ] does that mean
yeah
i mean what does that mean yeah what
does that mean are those more or less
than one percent those numbers that i
just read less 0.015 yeah 0.02
0.03 are those more or less than one
percent less they're definitely less
than one percent so when the active
active accounts actively manage accounts
there's something called aum
assets under management it's a aka
how much you're going to charge me to
manage my money and the typical fee is
one percent
so okay okay so if you invest a million
dollars one percent
ten thousand dollars yeah okay
now if you invest a million dollars
in a
vanguard
passive index fund
0.03
it's like 30 bucks yeah
huh 10 grand or 30 bucks yeah i'll take
the 30.
that's the whole point of passive
investing
that's the whole point so all these
different places invest into the same s
p 500 and they're just like i'll take
less from you that place will take uh
0.05 i'll take 0.03 exactly and that's
that's the competition it's who takes
less
but with actively managed the reason
that you're paying the one percent is
because you trust them to beat the
market right if they're not going to
beat the market why the hell would you
pay them more
do you have i mean which one are you
i've done it all you have all i've done
it all i've got index funds i've got
someone who's trying to beat the market
i test it out
okay i got target date funds yeah i
actively have them all i've got passive
funds i've got index fund i'm doing a
little bit and seeing what's going on
but for the most part keep it simple
for the most part you don't need to pay
someone to manage your money if you've
got a 401k at home
or a roth ira there's something called a
target date fund you get a robo advisor
that charges next to nothing just put it
in there
time investing is two things bro time
and compound interest the more time it's
in the market the more the compound
interest grows the more money you make
the more money you keep putting in the
more money you're going your money goes
up so i'm a huge fan of the stock market
i'm a huge fan of index investing there
it is i said it okay all right great so
yeah so whatever the price is i mean 30
bucks whatever you put in i mean yeah
just get into this index fund these
three are great three those are three
options there's a fourth option called
the s p 500 equal weight index i don't
want to get too nerdy here but basically
go back to that picture can you pull
that picture back up
so basically you see how some are bigger
than others some are you know so it's
called equal weight would be like
everything gets the same sliver
okay so obviously there's certain
companies amazon apple
jpmorgan chase bank of america google
microsoft right t for tesla these
companies are crushing it
so there's something called the fang
stocks are you familiar with fang no
f-a-a-n-g stands for facebook
apple amazon netflix google or alphabet
part of google whatever gotcha anyway
fang stocks make up i think um
like 40 of the s p see those big ass
blocks yeah it's taking a nice chunk of
change if you say look i don't invest in
the s p because some companies if they
go under that could they could be it
could screw me over i don't know i don't
know there's something called the weight
index s p 500 equal weight index where
each of these companies will be exactly
the same amount there's different
options you could do that's my point i'm
assuming less risk less reward in that
is that that type of touche touche but
if you don't know where to get started i
always say the easiest place to start is
a 401k or an ira or roth ira
cool that's like if you're traveling
that's your luggage
right but now you're going to put [ __ ]
in your luggage
so what do you put in your luggage
here's a great thing to put in your
luggage
s p 500 well sauce i mean i sure learned
something today hell yeah you have no
idea we bring it up every show yeah
index what is he saying what is he
saying this is me okay cool cool no idea
we're talking about well now do you have
a better idea totally so to use an
analogy
an account is like your luggage
hey i started 401k what kind of luggage
you're getting yeah cool i got the you
know i got the i got the big roll away
thing black whatever yeah you know i got
i got a that's your just your luggage
yeah now with what are you gonna put in
your luggage right like stocks are like
shirts
bonds are like jeans whatever you want
to look at it you need a bunch of
different [ __ ]
what are you going to throw in there
shoes socks you're traveling you're
traveling for a year
you need underwear you need pants you
need a stupid hat you got a fedora you
go to mexico you need an outfit
sombrero sombrero
but the point is you got to put stuff in
the luggage the s p 500 is basically
saying don't just put one stock in there
don't just put 10 stocks in there the
whole [ __ ] thing dude put 500 stocks
in there 500 sucks dude one of them is
gonna do good anyway exactly so they're
all going to do good so in in in and
pull up this picture i want people to
get this book
anyway there's a book out there
if you're looking for a book this book
is fantastic
jack bogle rest in peace he died a few
years ago pre-coveted uh what a g
okay i've got my money in vanguard full
disclosure you don't have to put your
money in vanguard to even read this book
i don't care
um
the whole point is he says this
he basically broke it down and this is
where i was like i don't know i got
money i'm making money i'm spending
money i don't know i got this
keep it simple keep your costs low and
stay the course
[Music]
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broke
[Music]
you